I think leaven is someone who he loathes
and detests everyone within there where
you could look and but probably no one
more so than himself I mean he probably
hates himself more than anything you
really get that vibe from them and that
world drives you crazy the gossip world
the guys who sort of although other than
which the destruction of people's
opinions is like I mean the biggest
problem with TMZ is that it's owned by
Warner Brothers years ago the studios
was in their interest to keep things
quiet about your love life your abortion
your going to the rehab you know now
some guy was sitting in a studio one day
like 25 years ago says why are we
killing ourselves to shield these morons
and all this garbage from the media
let's go the other way let's do a show
that makes fun of the ones who work for
us so when you go to Warner Brothers you
go down one hallway and you go make a
movie for them and you go down another
hallway in the same building and there's
harvey levin chopping your legs off does
that piss you off the most he gets out I
think it's appalling I've never in my
life understood that